[Music]
chuck you ready for another one oh yes
okay this is the topic of white noise
you know
no don't go there just stop
i'm just
since january 6. now that we bought it
up
no i did not bring it up now that we
brought it up our god it's just you know
since january 6 is happening
while we're on the subject
[Laughter]
white noise
was long defined before the chaos at the
capitol okay
all right
so uh white noise is what
is described
as a combination of sound frequencies
that ends up just
sounding like a like a hiss
it's a hit
okay right and so what's going on
as opposed to black noise
which is
shut them damn kids up
that's black noise
y'all know i'm down here trying to watch
my stories the hell is wrong with you
that is black noise
that is black noise
thank you chuck
we'll introduce that to the annals of
physics right
all right okay all right like i said
still enough silliness
so
uh so here it is so what it is it's a
mixture of all frequencies of sound oh
wow all at once okay all audible
frequencies of sound okay you could add
in others but it won't make any
difference because you can't hear them
okay so white noise is low frequency
middle frequency high frequency and the
different ways you can do it because
high frequency
sound at the same
amplitude actually carries more energy
so
you
you might
sort of adjust it so that you have the
same amount of energy
uh sound energy in each sort of
frequency band all right so the
different ways to define it the point
i'm making is all sam all frequencies of
sound
are
are sampled and what that sounds like to
you is a hiss
okay
so
they say
it's so unfortunate now that we live in
an age of digital streaming and cable
television
because
kids will never get to know
what white noise sounds like one day
when you're between channels when when
tvs were were actually grabbing
radio frequencies from the air yeah
right with with the antennas right if
you were between channels or if the
channel went off the air you would see
static on the screen and that would
sound that would be the sound of white
noise yes
oh by the way by the way
by the way
uh some fraction
a few percent of the hiss that is on
that screen
is the cosmic microwave background oh
that's hot as opposed to the world where
carol anne was taken in poltergeist oh
okay
i'm not authorized to speak further on
places such as that
so
so
so that's what it would look like if you
made sort of image on a screen but that
would be oh by the way that would be
electromagnetic noise so that's not
audio yes they turned a radio signal
into an acoustic signal right and that
acoustic signal comes across as a hiss
as a white noise all right that's so
cool that's so cool just to be clear
about that so now you have to ask
why is it called white so here's where
it comes from
if uh isaac newton
uh one day
uh the sun is shining through his window
and
he closes his curtains or cuts a hole in
the watch forgot which might have done
both and just one narrow beam of
sunlight comes through the wall
okay then he takes a prism
a 60 60 60 equilateral prism okay okay
and he puts the sunlight through the
prism
and on the other side of the prism comes
the rainbow
the colors red orange yellow green blue
violet
okay
but he had a mystical fascination with
the number seven and those six colors
don't sum to seven so he added one
mm-hmm which which color did he add
indigo indigo of course so we have red
orange yellow green blue indigo
violet
all right and that spells everybody's
friend roy g biv
okay we all love roy g bev all right yes
so there is almost as much as bell biv
developed
only knew he had a cousin called yg biv
if only they knew
so
um so
anyhow
so
it has all the colors there okay right
so the question is
did the prism
create these colors
because the white light is no longer
visible
right and this is what everyone presumed
of course it created the colors because
if they were there before it entered the
prison the prism you would see them we
see them of course so so then he said
well what will happen if i take another
prism
put these colors back through
let's see what then comes out the other
side
you know what came out the other side
white light
and so newton
was very clever not just because he was
smart but clever in his experiments and
what questions to ask and how to adjust
the experiment to test for things where
you it could be one thing or another but
let's readjust the test to distinguish
what explanation might account for it in
so doing he showed
that
white light from the sun is composed
of equal amounts of all the colors in
the rainbow
in the spectrum and by the way rainbows
people said oh the raindrops are making
the colors not the sun it's in the
sunlight
this is freaky how could color be in
white light
what the hell is going on okay well you
got to get into the physiology of the
retina and the brain and all that the
point is your eyes are racist
that
is how
all the white all the light is white
all the colors come in to your racist
eyes
and all they see is white
i'm afraid i have to just say that is
the physics to the tree
the only thing that comes out of the
rainbow flag is white that's it okay
there it is that's the physics of it so
the point is if you
combine all those frequencies of white
the red the orange the yellow the green
the blue the violet and combine them all
and you have equal amounts of them all
you get white
uh-huh
so
this word in that context was then
borrowed by the sound people
if you put equal frequencies of sound
okay it's not a thing it's just this
noise we shall call it white noise even
though the sound unless your synesthetic
where you have cross-wired
senses
the sound is not a color all right but
we assign we say it's white out of
homage to newton and the colors of the
spectrum and the fact that you put all
these colors
these different frequencies together and
you get the color white
so that hiss is white noise for that
reason
yeah you know and it's funny because it
is i i understand the the the borrowing
of the term that makes sense
be just because
it's the same picture of what yeah plus
you're using frequencies
frequencies right so sound waves light
waves the whole deal frequencies sound
makes sense but the the the the term
doesn't really fit
for like you say unless you're uh you
know
uh you have synesthesia it doesn't fit
we need a better term for white noise is
what i'm saying
okay
okay so the point is
noise
can be any combination of those
frequencies but when it's equal across
the board
only then is it white noise that's no
why can't it be equality noise
okay
dei noise diversity equity there you go
diversity equity and inclusiveness
that's what it's doing
and we can call it day day noise dei
noise
right now there are let me tell you
something right now there are some fox
news viewers that are watching us right
now and their heads are exploding their
heads are exploding right now bill maher
just threw up right now
because he's anti-woke oh yes he's so
anti-woke but yeah no it makes perfect
sense honestly to to borrow that
uh that picture but it's a very specific
kind of noise it really is otherwise
it's not white noise for example if you
had more
red in your spectrum than blue and you
mix them together the object will have a
red hue to it okay and if you have more
blue
in the mixture rather than red it would
have a blue hue to it in fact red stars
and blue stars in the sky are exactly
that they're giving you all frequencies
but they lean towards those the that
side of the spectrum that has those
colors so
um i i think it's okay to borrow terms
that make sense in other contexts i
don't have a problem with that yeah it
it paints the picture i mean you know
from the new the problem is not too many
people know the newton's story that's my
point is that
it makes perfect sense once once you
explain the newton's story i'm like oh
my god that that's awesome you know and
they like i get it now
and if your acoustic noise is clank
clankity clanking or or if you can find
any signal within that noise it's not
white noise it's not quite right exactly
right yeah right yeah oh that's it it's
very cool though okay that's what i just
set the record straight there yeah once
again i'm impressed
that she took you know something totally
stupid
[Music]
made it made it super interesting
and
and informative
i'll tell you something
i don't know how many times you can pull
this trick
later on that you come out with a with
an album
black noise
oh my god that should be my next album
black noise that is good that's good
that's a good name for an album that
could work that could work
black noise black noise you heard a
white noise here's some black noise
there you go shut the hell up
don't make me put my foot up your ass
there you go that's more black noise
all right
we gotta end everything
black noise and white noise make perfect
sense together okay
it's just like what the hell is going on
what how many times i would tell you
[Music]
all right we're done here uh yet another
explainer brought to you by star talk
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]